who are some guys that you would put in
that that level would musk like musk
well musk is musk right
um he's the Pinnacle but who else would
you put in that space I have respect for
anyone who's kind of similar I'm trying
to think of people who I idolize and
really look up to
some of them are Fighters like I always
loved Mayweather I think Mayweather is
the best boxer in history really yeah I
liked May weather I'm a huge fan best
boxer in history yeah ahead of Ali yeah
I mean Ali's Ali right but Mayweather's
never lost it's hard to he's never lost
anybody and I liked him because he was
so clinical and so precise and he took
his ego out of it and said I want to
have a longer career than everyone else
so I'm going to focus on not getting hit
and hitting him I may not get the
knockout all right I don't need the
knockout I've won just win clinical
chess win payday win payday you were
fighting was boring 100 bill whatever
100 Mil whatever boring cool next win he
was really smart so I like May weather
someone I've always looked up to and I
really respect